antes de empezar a resolver este
problema quiero comentarte que en
realidad de este problema no es un
chiste es bastante complicado pero pero
si lo hacemos paso a paso no es tan malo
definitivamente no es un problema fácil
pero pero no hay que ponerse tristes ni
desalentar sea la primera sino sabes por
dónde empezar así que vamos a resolverlo
dice sea p de x igual a 24 x a la 24 más
la suma desde jota igual a 1 hasta 23 de
24 - jota por equis a la 24 - j más x a
la 24 más j luego sean z1 sentados hasta
zr los distintos ceros de p de x es
decir aquellos números en donde el
polinomio sea nula y sea se está acá al
cuadrado igual a acá más beca y para
cada igual a uno hasta r es decir es el
cuadrado de los ceros verdad donde i es
la raíz imaginaria y es igual a la raíz
de menos uno
y acá y de acá son números reales
entonces acá es la parte real de este
número y bk en su parte imaginaria dice
sea la suma desde acá igual a 1 hasta r
del valor absoluto debe acá igual a m
más n por la raíz de pe donde m ene ips
son enteros y p no es divisible entre el
cuadrado de ningún primo calcula m más n
más p y por supuesto aquí nos dicen que
pe no es divisible entre el cuadrado de
ningún primo simplemente para decir que
esta raíz ya está completamente
simplificada muy bien ya ya no le
podemos sacar un factor extra que se
enteró entonces aquí está suma esta suma
de los becas la suma de los becas estos
veces becas es la parte imaginaria de
los ceros al cuadrado este de aquí es el
de la parte imaginaria de los ceros al
cuadrado ok entonces para poder ir
resolviendo esto vamos a necesitar o al
menos para mí
mejor y viendo quién quién es este
polinomio ok entonces nuestro polinomio
de x es igual a 24 x a la 24 este lo voy
a poner en otro color 24 x a la 24 más
qué pasa cuando jota es igual a 1
entonces tendremos 23 que multiplica
x a la 24 menos uno que es 23 más x a la
24 más uno que es 25 muy bien ahora qué
pasaría si jota es 2 y j es 2 tendremos
24 menos dos que son 22 que multiplica a
x a la 24 menos 2 que es 22 más x a la
24 más dos que son 26 entonces yo creo
que aquí ya se puede ver bien el patrón
de qué es lo que va a pasar aquí vamos a
sumar todos estos términos y así
sucesivamente hasta que lleguemos por
ejemplo a 2 x x el exponente coincide
con el coeficiente entonces aquí es x a
la dos más x elevado al que corresponde
a 2 sería
22 22 entonces tendremos 24 22 son 46
uno que multiplica a x a la 1 que
simplemente es x +
x a la 47 muy bien entonces tu disculpar
as que que los haya puesto de esta forma
pero bueno es para para realmente
fijarnos en cómo está realmente pensado
este polinomio ok entonces los
coeficientes van bajando desde el 24
hasta el 1 el primer exponente coincide
con el coeficiente verdad va
coincidiendo y también va bajando sin
embargo el segundo exponente empieza en
25 y empieza a subir hasta 47 ok
entonces cómo podemos reescribir p
podemos reescribirlo al menos a mí me
funciona escribirlo digamos en el orden
descendiente de los exponentes es decir
vamos a empezar poniendo en la equis que
tiene el exponente más grande y ese es x
a la 27 x a la 27 y tiene este
coeficiente luego x a la 26 pero quién
es el coeficiente es 2 verdad si hacemos
la distribución de este producto
y así vamos sumando verdad hasta llegar
a 22 x x a la 20 la haya quiera aquí me
equivoqué verdad es 47 47 y 46 y vamos
llegando a x a la 26
23 x a la 25 muy bien entonces ahora
sigue el que tiene x a la 24 pero x a la
24 es este magenta este este color azul
morado es más 24 x a la 24 y luego
sumamos
luego sumamos x a la 23 que tiene aquí
un 23 23 x a la 23 más 22 x a las 22 y
así seguimos sumando hasta 2
x cuadrada más x muy bien entonces esto
esto ya es mucho más fácil de ir
visualizando y realmente aquí te voy a
dar un truco te voy a dar un truco que
bueno después de haber haberlo estudiado
uno puede fácilmente reconocer este
problema primero antes que nada antes
que nada vamos a factorizar una equis si
te das cuenta todos los términos tienen
al menos un factor x entonces este
polinomio se puede ver como x que
multiplica a aquí sería x a la 46 más x
al a perón 2 x a la 45 más seguimos
sumando 22 x a la 25 más 23 x a la 24 y
luego sumamos el término morado que es
24 x al ala 23 entonces te recojo que
aquí ya estamos factor izando una equis
falta factorizar las de abajo y son
23 x a la 22 + 22 x a la 21 más seguimos
sumando 2x + 1 muy bien entonces x
multiplica a este polinomio y aquí
claramente x igual a 0 es una raíz de
este polinomio verdad porque justo
pudimos factorizar esta equis pero en
realidad no tiene mucho sentido
considerar esta raíz porque porque
queremos o bueno al menos al menos para
los fines de este problema queremos
sumarlas las partes imaginarias de las
raíces y la parte imaginaria de cero
pues es cero entonces bueno solo fue
algo bonito de observar así que vamos a
pensar a partir de este momento en todas
las raíces que sean distintas de cero es
decir las raíces de este polinomio de la
derecha por el cual está multiplicando x
verdad y para poder analizar esto quiero
que vean este truco que a mí me parece
fantástico
vamos vamos a ver si recuerdan cómo
elevar polinomios al cuadrado piensen
por ejemplo en x 1 x 1 al cuadrado bueno
ya lo hemos visto hasta el cansancio en
otros vídeos
esto será x cuadrada más 2 x más 1 muy
bien entonces ahora qué pasa si tenemos
x cuadrada más x más 1 y esto lo
elevamos al cuadrado entonces bueno
pensemos vamos a tener que multiplicar
este polinomio por sí mismo si no si no
recuerdas cómo te recomiendo que cheques
los vídeos de multiplicación de
polinomios entonces sería x cuadrada que
multiplica todo esto sería x cuadrada
por x cuadrada es x a la cuarta es x a
la cuarta perdón x cuadrada por x son x
al cubo x cuadrada x 1 es x cuadrada muy
bien ahora vamos a multiplicar x por
todo este polinomio y es x x x cuadrada
es x al cubo x x x es
es cuadrada y x por 1 es x finalmente si
multiplicamos a 1 por este mismo
polinomio tendremos x cuadrada + x + 1
ahora si lo sumamos obtenemos este
resultado verdad el resultado de elevar
al cuadrado x cuadrada + x + 1 y nos
queda x a la cuarta más 2 x al cubo más
3 x cuadrada y creo que ya estás viendo
el patrón esto es 12 x + 1 si te das
cuenta se parece muchísimo a la idea que
tenemos en este porque aquí también va
aumentando el coeficiente llega a su
máximo y después llega a su máximo y
después empieza a decrecer es más aquí
hasta parece que esté 24 x a la 23 que
correspondía
a este primer sumando hasta parece que
lo pusieron a propósito verdad quizás lo
hice aún a propósito entonces con esto
observado ya puedes darte cuenta de a
dónde vamos a llegar con esto
de hecho tú podrías hacer fácilmente lo
siguiente x al cubo más x cuadrada me
faltó ahí ahí esta x cuadrada más x más
1 si lo elevamos al cuadrado bueno tú
puedes hacerlo a pie digamos puedes
hacer las cuentas pero si seguimos este
patrón y que de hecho si es cierto lo
puedes demostrar fácilmente
esto sería x sería el x al cubo al
cuadrado sería x a la 6
luego más 2 x a las 5 más
x a la 4 verdad más
o que iba a ir algo x al cubo más algo x
al cuadrado más algo por x más 1 verdad
entonces que iba 12 aquí va 3 y aquí va
4 entonces si se quedó bastante bien y
si te das cuenta cuál es el término con
el coeficiente más grande el término con
el coeficiente más grande es el que es
justo el que queda a la mitad verdad
aquí hay 3 acá de este lado hay 3 y
justo el que quedó a la mitad es el que
tiene el coeficiente más grande todavía
más si si nosotros queremos saber cuál
fue el polinomio que elevamos al
cuadrado pues simplemente nos fijamos en
este exponente verdad entonces el
polinomio habrá sido el x al cubo más x
cuadrada más x más 1 por ejemplo aquí
está este término de enmedio y el
polinomio que fue elevado fue x al
cuadrado más x más 1 verdad éste nos da
el primer término del polinomio que
estamos elevando al cuadrado así que con
él
uno podría ver fácilmente de aquí que el
término que tiene el coeficiente más
grande es justamente este que es un 24 y
por lo tanto el polinomio que elevamos
es el que empieza con x a la 23 entonces
pd x simplemente lo escribimos como x
que multiplica a x a la 23 más x a la 22
más x a la 21 y así seguimos sumando
hasta x al cubo más x cuadrada más
+ x + x1 muy bien entonces qué es lo que
tenemos aquí esto teníamos que elevarlo
al cuadrado muy bien lo elevamos al
cuadrado y aquí tenemos ya la expresión
distinta o al menos un poco simplificada
de quién es nuestro polinomio voy a
dejar a este vídeo aquí pero vamos a
necesitar otro par de vídeos que
incluirán este tipo de ideas geniales
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo